(swooshing)
- [Jughead voiceover]
The summer before your
junior year in high school,
and how do you spend it?
♪ Silence is deafening ♪
♪ In storms still stuck in the clouds ♪
Maybe you spent it on trial
for a murder you didn't commit.
- [Old Man] You impressed me
today, you've been tapped.
♪ My eyes up to give love ♪
♪ Hit the sound ♪
- [Jughead] You're breaking
Archie out of Juvie?
- [Archie] Your dad is still out there,
as long as we're together,
I don't think I can go back to Riverdale.
- If you loved me,
you would come home.
♪ The rain starts pouring down ♪
- [Jughead voiceover]
What returned to Riverdale
was something far different from
the redheaded boy next door.
♪ The greatest show in town ♪
- So, what did I miss?
- Well.
♪ Welcome to the end of the world ♪
- My God.
♪ The end of the world ♪
- [Hermoine] Dilton Doiley and Ben Button
were found in the woods with blue lips.
- Griffins and Gargoyles.
- We thought it was just
a game, but it's not.
He's real, the Gargoyle King.
- This game is literally killing people.
- So my dad played G&G in high school.
- [Betty] All of our parents did.
- They're in danger, our
children, it's happening again.
- Where'd you get this?
- It was in my locker,
same with everyone else.
♪ Come to the flames ♪
♪ Feels so good when they lick your skin ♪
- [Jughead Jones] All of its connected.
They make drugs inside the prison,
which all the kids take
when they play G&G.
(thud)
- Here's your drug money.
- You're Jughead's mom.
- We got the whole town JB.
- I could feel it
(clinking)
- Everything's going
just how you said mom.
- One more thing, don't tell
Jughead about our business.
- You broke the code, turn
in your jackets and go.
- I'm a Serpent by blood, you
can't take that away from me.
♪ Come one come all to the greatest show ♪
- [Cheryl] What's this?
- [Toni] The Pretty Poisons.
- [Cheryl] And you're the leader?
- Can I kiss you?
- Archie...
♪ Welcome to the end of the world ♪
- Mom, you're actually
buying this farm crap.
Some huckster's is selling you.
- The farm gave me back my brother.
♪ Welcome to the end of the world ♪
- There's a refrigerator filled
to the brim with human organs.
- [Charles] It's vital
that we find your mom,
in fact I'm Charles, your brother.
- The true master behind
the Gargoyle King,
was you Penelope.
- My revenge on a town, that's
a hideous and cruel place.
Now it's time to play one final round.
Begin!
- [Betty] Dad?
- You either shoot me or I'll shoot you.
- [Penelope] Enough!
(cracking)
♪ Welcome to the end of the world. ♪
- [Jughead voiceover]
Riverdale belonged to us again.
- Oh yeah!
- [Jughead voiceover] The
future was ours to write,
but what would our stories be?
- I'm gonna stay in Riverdale
while your dad's away.
- Son, I will always love you.
- Guys, we've got senior year
ahead of us, let's enjoy it.
- Friends forever?
- Sure!
Let's toast.
- To the future.
(clinging)
(hawk screaming)
(crackling)
- We have to burn all of our clothes,
including Jughead's beanie.
We never speak of this,
ever.
Do it!
♪ Welcome to the end of the world ♪